i got two boys i'm asking him for a
different reason i'm not nine and eight
so i want to go back to
how long did you train to box what's the
total timeline from the day you started
training to you winning those three
fights two days in a row and now three
months okay so here's my question for
you were you were you a street fighter
my brother was so so so he was this is
your brother yeah that's my older
brother he's my manager too so you
you're a tour manager so you were the
fighter you fought yeah he had the anger
issues
so he's your older brother you pick on
you as a kid oh dude i was my record
against him was like one in seventy
thousand
dollars
he's flexing he's flexing right now
yeah we have to go to anger management
and [ __ ] yeah he has issues but but what
i'm asking is like he's better now he's
better now he seems like very likable
did the kids in aurora would did they
fear him like
that's what i'm asking they feared him
but not me now you you were the fun guy
let's hang out let's party with him but
man i don't want to mess with you
correct like you mess with me you got to
mess with my brother but this is kind of
where i want to go this one i want to go
i'm looking at the model right on how
this thing works so
i know guys that trained boxing for six
years and they're still not golden
gloves yes okay
you go you're an athlete you come and
you start boxing three months later boom
you're winning six and under you win a
big fight hey golden gloves champion now
you're making the next round on you you
pop sees you knocking out the guy that
there's no way that's going to be taking
place
how much of this is
pure athleticism how much of it is
purely genetics how much of it is a guy
can come off the street as a football
player you know who's a full-on athlete
get in the ring and fight because we're
seeing what's going on today a lot of
these guys that are not working it's not
working out so that's what i'm trying to
say so where was it where you
had the edge over your opponents even
though you've only trained boxing for
three months or you're not like a street
fighter no yeah i think the mentality i
just to me i like uh i just always
outworked everybody always even in three
months but three months is not a long
time it's not a long time but i was
around like greatness i had a great
coach and then i think you know athletic
ability is a big thing yeah and then
toughness is a really really big thing
especially at the golden gloves level
like toughness is
huge
that's why you're asking those questions
about how tough the mafia
with toughness i'm not i'm not obsessed
i don't really like this respectfully no
i hear you no i'm not i'm just curious
like yeah do we think they're tough like
like that was the the the iceman killer
like the man you killed all those guys
yeah like
you're talking about a serial killer
like these guys are [ __ ] serial
killers and we idolize them like these
guys aren't [ __ ] man yeah you can put
that gun down and take off your [ __ ]
armani suit i got some friends that beat
the [ __ ] out of him that's like the the
yeah from friday the the pops remember
he's like you think you're tough with a
gun this
but this is he said it perfectly before
man the levels so like there's guys that
have been wrestling their whole life and
they're really really really good sick
technical wrestlers and they're as tough
as nails and they lead face first and
everything but they're not strong and
they're not big and they're not fast so
somebody who's big strong fast learns a
little bit of technique there's nothing
that guy can do to them then you know so
they always talk about like you know
technique will be you know size and
athleticism yeah until science and
athleticism learns a little bit of
technique but then you get to a certain
level the level you got to where then
you've got the athlete who has the
technique
but even that caught up with me like i
felt like i was a cheat code in a video
game because i excelled so fast through
the rankings like knocked out crow cop
who has a million years experience
former world champion i knock him out
i'm ranked in the top ten and they're
like here's noguera in brazil which i
asked for here's big nog in brazil i'm
like i'm gonna smoke this old man
you're thinking that i was like yeah i
was like i'm gonna destroy this dude in
his hometown brazil
and then you know i ended up getting
knocked down that fight but because i
was
it was a cheat code man because i was
really athletic really really big but
eventually going to come across where
experiences came considering because no
guerra has seen the big athletic young
kid with a good right hand who's very
athletic and fast so when i remember
throwing all these faints at him he's
not reacting like what the [ __ ] is going
on he's seen it a million times like he
wasn't impressed so eventually if you
don't have that experience and the ufc
is not a not a league where you want to
try and gain expansion and get cut so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]